buongiorno la mia storia oggi è sulla un
po dal contesto da tutte le altre
diversa da tutte le altre
perché una storia che riguarda molto ma
molto il privato ma tante volte il
privato diventa sociale perché alcune
cose
alcuni fatti alcune vicende non possono
rimanere nello personale ma riguardano
tutti il mio muro il muro che ho dovuto
abbattere è stato il muro della violenza
il mio muro della sopraffazione
il muro dell'omertà del silenzio della
violenza vi sto parlando di mafia mafia
non intesa soltanto come colui che spara
o mette una bomba come manovalanze
classico la mafia in mezzo a noi la
mafia riveste il doppio petto è una
mafia invisibile e quella del potere e
io ho lottato contro un potere
la mia lotta è stata quella della
memoria contro contro l'oblio il mio la
mia storia la storia di un dolore che si
è fatta impegno la storia di un lutto
che diventa rinascita e della memoria
che è diventata riscatto
inizia in una strada di reggio calabria
in una splendida mattina di maggio era
il 3 maggio del 1982 quando un
imprenditore si chiamava gennaro musella
ed era mio padre
esce di casa mette in moto la sua
autovettura e salta in aria
la sua macchina vedete
queste sono le immagini è stata fatta a
pezzi così come il suo corpo ridotto a
brandelli sparso un po di là un po di
qua il cervello la macchia del cervello
è rimasta per lungo tempo sul balcone di
una casa di fronte la ragione non può
quando non capisce non riesce a
rassegnarsi si rischia di impazzire
quando non si capisce perché si deve pur
dare un senso a qualcosa ma questa cosa
ha un senso non aveva mi sono costituita
subito parte civile avendo fiducia in
una giustizia allora avevo ancora
fiducia nella giustizia ma la giustizia
da noi la giustizia è molto lenta una
giustizia che soffre una giustizia
malata
sì che dopo otto anni il caso mi è stato
chiuso contro ignoti che ignoti non
erano ma non mi sono rassegnata
ho continuato a cercare la verità ho
richiesto la riapertura del caso
in seguito a delle nuove vicende ma non
mi è stata data nessuna risposta sì che
ancora più fermamente convinta io salito
gradini del tribunale di reggio calabria
mi sono recata dal magistrato che aveva
quelle indagini
gli ho chiesto perché non mi desse
risposta
la risposta che mi ha dato è stato
abbastanza traumatica detto ma lei
signora non si rende conto che ha due
figli pensi ai suoi figli e se ne stia a
casa
ecco quello è stato il momento in cui è
iniziata la mia battaglia un momento in
cui da essere umano mi sono sentita
mortificata mi sono sentita impotente ma
subito dopo
diciamo io sono napoletana da noi a
napoli si dice nasce la forza dalla
disperazione
ecco la mia forza è nata dalla
disperazione e ho deciso di cercare
quella giustizia che non riuscivo a
trovare nelle aule dei tribunali nelle
coscienze della gente
quindi ho deciso di raccontare di
testimoniare perché la gente potesse
rendersi conto di quello che succedeva e
ho iniziato dai giovani beh ragazzi io
in tutti questi anni son 24 anni che
giro le scuole in tutta italia e anche
all'estero
ho raccontato non mi sono mai smesso di
raccontare di fare testimonianza di fare
memoria perché ritengo che una società
diversa possa essere creata soltanto se
con giovani diversi con giovani che
siano informati e formati perché loro
devono conoscere le cose per poterle
combattere e così ho fatto vedete quando
muore un uomo delle istituzioni pensiamo
a falcone e borsellino sono le
istituzioni stesse che ricordano i loro
uomini ma quando a morire è un cittadino
comune i palazzi sono molto lontane e se
io non mi fossi messa in gioco come
tanti altri familiari di vittime in
questo paese
se io non mi fossi messo in gioco mio
padre sarebbe stato dimenticato sarebbe
morto per una seconda volta
io ho combattuto ho imposto la sua
memoria ad uno stato sordo se pensate
che il ministero dell'interno scritto
alla mia famiglia soltanto dopo 26 anni
nel frattempo mia mamma ha cresciuto da
sola quattro figli
io ho cresciuto dal suolo i miei il
ministero ci ha ricordato dopo ben 26
anni ma pensate che il ministero si
sarebbe ricordato di un uomo morto
disintegrato in una strada di reggio
calabria
se io non avessi dato voce a quella
morte sia non avessi urlato se io non
avessi preteso verità e giustizia
sicuramente no ecco perché dico che ho
imposto quella morte e l'ho voluta
ricordare con un fiore questore che
avete visto e la gerbera gialla che
negli anni è diventato poi simbolo della
resistenza anti mafia simbolo della vita
quel fiore è stato dato a migliaia e
migliaia di ragazzi negli anni ragazzi
che nel mese di maggio mese in cui è
morto mio padre ma in cui si ricordano
tante stragi di mafia dimostrano
scendono in piazza contro la mafia è
nata nel 92 a reggio calabria questo
fiore proprio in ricordo di quella
strage e ogni anno a maggio ritorna a
fiorire questo fiore importante perché è
diventato un simbolo un simbolo di
memoria ma soprattutto un simbolo di
reazione di rinascita di riscatto
questo io ho cercato per tutti questi
anni il riscatto e penso di esserci
riuscita
perché oggi quella via in cui mio padre
è stato fatto a pezzi porta il suo nome
porta il suo nome una strada all'isola
d'elba
un'altra strada a salerno
una palestra quella di scampia dei
maddaloni intitolata a lui una scuola
e allora la memoria che vive ecco perché
vi dicevo la memoria diventa riscatto e
io posso dire oggi che mio padre
continua a vivere nei cuori di tutti
questi ragazzi che incontro che incontrò
nel quotidiano
continua a vivere nel ricordo della
gente nel ricordo delle istituzioni
attraverso quel poco o molto che io sono
riuscito a fare ma credo di aver
riscattato mio padre di aver riscattato
la sua memoria di aver riscattato un
cittadino comune oggi lo stato lo
ricorda lo ricorda in via ufficiale
perché ogni anno scende il presidente
del senato italiano in occasione della
scala strage dell'anniversario della
strage ogni anno il 3 maggio viene
ricordato in modo solenne ma a me per me
l'importante è che ogni ragazzo ricordi
gennaro musella nel proprio cuore e nei
ricordi soprattutto ne segua l'esempio
grazie a tutti